clinical trials for covid19 vaccines are
nearing the final stretch
but health experts say vaccines are just
one piece of a larger puzzle
in fighting the deadly disease and
getting us back to normal
the other big piece are effective
treatments for those who are already
sick
not everybody mounts a good immune
response in particular
immunosuppressed patients are well known
to not
respond well to vaccines so we are going
to need to have therapies for those who
are not vaccinated
and for those who don't make a good
immune response right now there are
three main categories of covid19
treatments
antibody therapies immunomodulators and
antivirals
antibody therapies leverage antibodies
like these
that the body naturally produces after
recovering from a disease
to ward off infection they attach to
proteins on the virus's surface
that prevents it from infiltrating cells
different types of antibodies
target different parts of the virus they
circulate in the yellowish liquid part
of blood known as plasma
that's where the treatment comes in you
can take that liquid
and give it to a person who's sick or to
prevent disease
so it is the transfer of immunity from a
person who's made it
to a person who's susceptible when given
to sick patients
convalescent plasma can potentially
boost a person's immune response to the
virus
but just for a few weeks we always pull
it out during
a pandemic we did this for 2009 h1n1
obviously for things such as ebola virus
disease in
in africa because it's relatively easy
to produce compared to vaccines and
other drugs
experts think it could possibly be used
both as a treatment
and as a preventative medicine against
covet 19. it's based
on the same principle of if you have a
protective antibody
passive transfer of that could provide
not only protection
prophylactically but also treatment
plasma is widely thought to be safe
and in august the fda authorized using
it to treat patients hospitalized with
coping 19
but its effectiveness is still being
studied convalescent plasma is a little
bit of a
it's a mixed bed we don't actually know
the titers
of the patients who have survived and
done well after covid
titus are a measurement of how many
antibodies are in a person's blood
typically the more antibodies a person
has the better chance they have at
fighting an
infection this means that not all plasma
is created equal
the amount and quality of antibodies it
contains can vary
that impacts how effective the treatment
can be so what you're getting with
complex
plasma right now is is a bit of an
unknown to overcome this
scientists use plasma as a blueprint to
build a more potent drug known as
monoclonal antibodies
they do this by homing in on specific
antibodies
that do the best job in stopping the
virus we screened
this huge panel of antibodies through
many in vitro assays
to select the best antibodies that block
the ability of the virus to get inside
cells and infect them
once they're identified scientists can
mass produce them in facilities that
resemble breweries
and pack them into drugs that act as a
targeted attack against the virus
you're growing these cells in
bioreactors which are huge steel tanks
and then as the cells grow they are
pumping out an antibody you are
concentrating that and in purified form
this is what you are administering to
patients
both regeneron and competitor eli lily
have been racing to bring monoclonal
antibody drugs to market for cobit 19.
the companies are testing drugs that
contain one or two types of antibodies
and researchers say they could have
benefits over plasma based treatments
monoclonal antibody preparations are
consistent
they are consistent from patient to
patient they can be standardized
and they are hopefully easier to use
than plasma because of these properties
each of the companies has released
encouraging data from early stage
clinical trials
showing that drugs helped reduce
coronavirus levels and improved symptoms
in non-hospitalized patients
but both drug makers had to pause their
studies in hospitalized patients
and the lilly study was halted in this
patient population altogether because
they didn't see a benefit
early data among less severe patients
though looks promising for both drugs
in october president trump was given
regeneron's antibody cocktail
as part of his covet 19 treatment the
president said the drug was key to his
recovery
but it's unclear how beneficial the drug
actually was
i just want to say we have regeneron we
have a very similar
drug from eli lilly and they're coming
out and we're trying to get them
on an emergency basis both regeneron and
lily have asked the fda
to authorize emergency use of their
treatments we have committed to
manufacturing about 300
000 dose of these antibodies by the end
of this year and we have also partnered
with raw so that we can scale up and
produce about two million dose of these
antibodies
to be available annually for worldwide
for worldwide use but physicians have
expressed concerns about these new drugs
this isn't the type of drug that is
always
able to be scaled that can be made
available to everyone rapidly
and also is is a low cost
experts say both plasma and monoclonal
antibody treatments
could help not just cover 19 patients
but also help prevent infection in
healthy people
to treat patients doctors have also been
using immunomodulators
these drugs suppress the immune system
in ensuing inflammation
in the sickest of coven 19 patients
that's important because this
inflammation can be deadly
one of those drugs is the steroid
dexamethasone
researchers have found that it improved
survival when given to severely ill
patients
the other treatment being used to fight
cobit 19 is the antiviral drug
remdezavir
this was another drug the president was
given at walter reed hospital
so we really try to give room desevere
as soon as somebody may be
admitted to the hospital we want to give
it as early as possible we know from
tamiflu and the flu and all those kind
of different drugs that giving
antivirals sooner rather than later is
really important
here's how it stops the coronavirus when
a virus infects the cell
it uses the cells machinery to build
more viruses
it does that by making copies of its rna
that's the genetic material that
contains instructions for replication
remdezavir is designed to infiltrate
these instructions
by inserting itself into copies of the
virus's genetic code
this interrupts the replication process
and acts as a kill switch for the virus
promising clinical trials led to the
drug being approved for emergency use in
may
but more recent studies have produced
conflicting results about its ability to
speed up recovery and curb death in
covet 19 patients
the department of health and human
services allowed drug maker gilead to
market the drug directly to hospitals in
october
and the ceo said he was confident in
being able to deliver the drug to the
patients who need it we now have enough
supply
of this medicine for patients in the
united states
and globally by the end of this month
there's been tremendous progress in
treating copit19
but health experts caution that there is
still more work to be done
to see just how effective these
treatments are and to save lives
doctors will need a multitude of drugs
at their disposal i think that we're
going to see many more
therapeutics come out by the end of this
pandemic and so that
people that enter the hospital will at
least receive one specific
cova-19 treatment for their disease
experts say these three types of
treatments are promising
and they are hopeful that therapeutic
drugs combined with the vaccine
may finally put up an effective defense
against the pandemic